[موسيقى]
اسرار
العمر 25 سنه بشتغل في مطاعم شاورما
وسنكان تحضير السندويشات الدجاج والبرجر
بس ظروف المدينه
اشتغل اشتغل
فيها الحمد لله تم قبول فيها من بعدها
اشتغلت فنون درست فنون طهي همم
الطبيخ الغربي اللي انا كنت عم بتمح لانه
اوصل لها
كانت طفولتي عباره عن انه فتاه كانت تطمح
للوصول لانها تكون شيف بس شفت الطبيخ
الغربي بس كان الظروف هضدها مع اسرار
والدتي والحمد لله اااا اسرارها علي
وقفتها جنبي
اعطتني شويه الظروف من ناحيه معدله في
التوجيهي بس الحمد لله لما وصلتنا المنحه
كان تشجيع والدتي بزياده اني ادخل هاي
المنحه عشان اوصل للهدف اللي انا بدي اياه
وانا متاكده انه انا راح اوصل للحذف اللي
انا بدي اياه من اول ما دخلت المطعم كانت
كانت
قويه وشديده لانه اخاف انه احرق همم
دجاج بخاف منه احرق ساندويش حاليا لا بعد
التعلم والاصرار همم صرت اطلع المواد سهله
جدا باساليب سهله جدا التعامل مع الناس
كنت اخاف انه اتعامل مع الناس همم شغلي
خلاني اقوى خلاني اعرف كيف اتعامل مع
الناس كلام اكبر بجهد اكبر همم
باستمتاع ايه بنظره للحياه اكثر ايجابيه
امم عكس شغلي عكس علي طريقه التفكير كيف
المجتمع بيفكر كيف انا بلشت اطلع على حليب
الطريقه الثانيه كيف انه انا قادره انه
اوصل رغم انه في شباب حوالي ضليت مصر
للهدف اللي انا بدي اياه بالاتقان يعني
انا بدي اياه بتعلم المزيد من الاشياء
الموجوده بجميع الاشكالها
انه ابلش همم اشتغل في المحل كامل وفي
الشغل كامل
بس
اا كل هذا السعيد لانه اوصل اني اكون شف
بس بالمطبخ الغربي
[موسيقى]